we don't officially have the slightest
belief in mind reading we scoff at the
Absurd idea that we might telepathically
know what number between one and a
million a stranger is thinking of or
that we could place our hands on someone
else's skull and thereby Intuit the
precise details of what they dreamed of
last night but in relationships whatever
our professed skepticism we very
frequently proceed as if mind reading
were not only possible but a standard
requirement and possibility in love
something of whose absence we would have
every right to complain with bitterness
and surprise in a great many ways we
simply assume that our partner must
automatically be able to know the
movements and preoccupations of our
minds and our expectations show up in
one of the standard ways in which we
speak of the Perfection of a lover in
the initial days of rapture they seem to
know what we are thinking without us
needing to speak
but our superstitious commitment to mind
reading soon evolves into something
darker as relationships proceed for
example when we get Huffy that our
partner didn't realize that our
off-color comment was only a joke we
can't imagine they could even think we'd
like the bizarre birthday present they
bought us
we're offended that they like a book
we've already decided is silly we're
annoyed that they didn't know we
wouldn't want to go to the mountains
this summer they can't understand the
mood we are in when we get back from
having lunch with our mother
we get worked up because we can't
conceive that certain ideas and feelings
that are so vivid in our minds should
not immediately be obvious to someone
who professes to care for us
we quickly fall into believing that the
partner's in comprehension can only be
explained in one way it must come down
to willfulness or nastiness
and therefore it seems only fair that we
respond with one of our standard forms
of punishment due to all those who
should have known better assault that
paradoxical pattern of behavior in which
we refuse for several hours or even a
day or two to reveal what is wrong to
our confused partner because they should
just know
the origins of our Reckless hopes are in
a sense extremely touching when we were
little a parent really did at Key
moments seemed to know what we were
thinking without us needing to speak as
if by Magic they guessed that we might
want some milk with a medium's genius
they determined that we needed a bath or
a nap or that a blanket was a bit
scratchy for our cheek and from this an
equation formed in our minds whenever I
am properly loved I do not need to
explain
but however great our parents were at
reading our minds they had a huge
advantage over our partners we were back
then really very simple our requirements
were usefully few we needed only to be
fed bathed slept taken to the potty and
entertained with a picture book or a bit
of string but we had no Advanced views
on politics we had no complicated
opinions on interior design our psyches
didn't register faint Tremors of sarcasm
or hypocrisy we couldn't be thrown off
course by the pronunciation of a word
how much more complicated we have grown
since then we are now adults who can
feel very strongly that a table must be
placed symmetrically in a room 20
centimeters from the door to the kitchen
or we like it very much when a partner
rolls up their sleeves but we hate them
wearing a short sleeved shirt especially
the green one we like being teased but
only sometimes and never about our age
we are very critical of our mother but
can't allow anyone to mention her habit
of being late we come across as
confident but think of ourselves as shy
we like art but have an aversion to
museums we love Stone fruits but hate
peaches we talk a lot about politics but
can't stand reading newspapers our
partners inability to know all this fast
and decisively necessarily feels like an
intimate insult and the complex task of
explaining our thoughts and attitudes
like an unreasonable imposition
but once we accept that there is no such
thing as mind reading a central part of
our relationship becomes the slow
careful process of piecing together in
one another's company what matters to us
and why with all the surprise and
moments of genuine Revelation this
entails we accept that there will be an
immense amount we need to teach each
other about who we are pretty much every
day while trusting that this is not an
attack on the idea of love